foreign
Alabama what do you got for us it's time
for TK's tweet up the week oh I'm
calling this one music to my ears I'm
calling this one A Portrait of calendar
clutter
let me first say this you don't have to
live like this although I know so many
people who live exactly like this in
fact they think it's virtuous the
picture you see on your screen right now
is a picture of one person's calendar
for a day
and it not only is aesthetically a
nightmare
but it causes stress for me can you read
the Tweet itself oh my god oh gosh yes I
can read this terrible looking Tetris
board this comes from Claire vo as a
chief product officer I'm one of the
lucky folks that get to live my perfect
work day every day 30 recruiting five
percent being recruited 50 people in
team 30 strategy 40 I see work 30
customers 20 yelling okrs into the wind
five percent coding oh my gosh this
gives me so much anxiety seems like like
300 busy yes exactly I didn't do the
math there but I'm not good at math but
yeah that definitely exceeds 100 and I
think the problem here is it presupposes
being busy is the most important thing
filling every minute of every day is the
most important thing but what are you
doing with those hours what are you
creating who are you serving how are you
adding value and by the way if this is
the best way to add value then so be it
I'm not saying I'm against this for
everyone I'm certainly against living
like this for me because I used to have
a calendar like this and it made no time
for spontaneity but it also made no time
for me I was absent from this calendar
and so I had to let that go if you look
at my calendar today there's almost
nothing on it if you look at my calendar
this week there are very few things on
it so I can say yes to the most
important things yeah if you work for
her are you free to admit that you don't
like the way they count under looks
here's what I will say
in Devil's Advocate defense of Claire
I'm gonna take her word for it when she
says that's her dream schedule and if
that's her dream schedule
I can't be a hypocrite and say I love
stories about Kobe Bryant being up at
three o'clock in the morning when
everybody else is getting home from the
club working on his free throws
um I'm not so eager to hop on the
anti-hustle Bro train that I will
condemn anybody who finds joy and
getting after it and working hard just
because it looks differently than the
way I want it to look at the same time
uh there is definitely a social game
that happens in a lot of workplaces
where people are driving themselves into
the ground and and this is sort of like
the uh the calendar version of laughing
at your boss's jokes that you don't
think is funny because you want to be in
good right and for a lot of people it's
sort of like memetic desire is is
heaviest in that kind of space where
people have lost themselves a long time
ago because they're trying so hard to
look productive one of the reasons why a
lot of people
started to experience so much joy and
freedom when when we were kind of forced
to go remote is because they achieved
this state of being able to be judged by
the quality of their output rather than
how hard it looks like they're working
there are a lot of people in workspaces
who it's not about the value they create
it's about the Optics that they got to
keep up and those games are silly so if
anybody is looking at that thinking that
that's how you need to be to be a player
in the world that's silly there's so
many ways to be productive and make
money you don't have to be like that but
if that's Claire's dream more power to
you because I'm sure my dreams look
crazy and stressful to other people too
I totally agree yeah and if that's
Claire's dream Brava to her yeah please
don't batter me with your dreams
because that would make me fake busy
right yeah I'm busy but my busyness
would be fake because it wouldn't be in
alignment with what I want to do with my
days what I want to do with my calendar
and it would stress me out in a way that
is counter productive and so if it works
for you yeah great but I decided to opt
out of calendar clutter a long time ago
professor John I just want to play
Devil's Advocate as well I'm looking at
this closely and Wednesday morning at 10
A.M there's a half hour block called DNS
and looking at the Twitter thread uh
Claire clarifies that that means do not
schedule so she is setting that boundary
Wednesday
at 10 A.M for a half hour good for her
yeah I love it
I mean here's the thing though like that
is the irony of this is yeah I used to
have to block off times as well in the
corporate world right but I only have
half an hour that I can actually block
off right and the irony is like oh but
what if I need a day what if I have a
project I want to start working on this
is when boundaries become too rigid
we've set up this many boundaries I
don't make room for any of the
spontaneity if I freeze all of the water
in my house how am I going to drink any
of it
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free